[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radiofrance internacional y France 24
Francia 24 esta semana hablamos de la
tensión y la de la violencia que han
marcado las últimas jornadas de huelga
aquí en Francia y también Hablamos del
relanzamiento del diálogo entre las
partes nos acompañan en este estudio
Luisa corradini corresponsal de la
nación bienvenida
jeanfredix historiador investigador de
la escuela de altos estudios en ciencias
sociales bienvenido Hola qué tal Gabriel
a bravos corresponsal de Radio
Cooperativa de chile bienvenida mucho
gusto y a distancia Federico tarragón y
sociólogo en la universidad París iderot
bienvenido Buenos días gracias por la
invitación en la emisión bueno es el
mono tema en Francia la movilización es
contra la reforma de las pensiones nos
preguntamos hay luz al final del túnel
hoy en Primera Plana
[Música]
la tensión y la violencia han marcado
las últimas jornadas de huelga en
Francia contra la reforma de las
pensiones movilizaciones
pero también una espiral de tensión de
la que nadie ya sabe muy bien cómo salir
la semana que viene se reactivará el
diálogo entre la primera ministra
Elizabeth Board y los sindicatos luego
de un pulso radicalizado a partir del
decreto con el que macron aprobó su
reforma eludiendo el voto de la asamblea
nacional hace dos semanas desde entonces
convocatorias espontáneas en redes
sociales y paros continuos en distintos
sectores especialmente en energía y
transportes han dominado la agenda
social y política del país hasta cuándo
Francia puede aguantar instalada en esta
situación nos lo preguntamos todos los
días la verdad aquí Qué elemento podría
producir un cambio en alguna de las
posturas repasemos algunas portadas que
nos trae la prensa Liberación Dónde está
la salida se pregunta el rotativo con la
foto de un presidente macron en
pequeñecido y caminando solo en el vacío
diario La El desafío del mantenimiento
del orden tras los estallidos de
violencia el semanario Land titula
democracia sobre brasas tras los últimos
acontecimientos sucedidos en Francia
Bueno luego les voy a preguntar por ese
compás de espera en el que nos
encontramos con esta crisis a espera de
que se retome el diálogo la semana que
viene pero antes de nada toda esta
crisis que arrastra Francia Luisa desde
hace ya dos meses qué está mostrando de
la Democracia ahora mismo estamos La
pregunta es correcta porque no es la
democracia en Francia es la democracia
Qué es lo que está pasando con la
democracia el cambio de las sociedades
que cada vez son más tienen más
desconfianza en la democracia
tradicional y en los dirigentes en
consecuencia lo que se ve prácticamente
en todo el mundo es que antes la gente
protestaba es verdad manifestaba exigía
de sus dirigentes pero en función de un
objetivo común y para lograr un objetivo
común a toda la sociedad en este momento
da la sensación de que las protestas en
el mundo entero son sobre todo
destituyentes es van en contra de todo
lo que es la autoridad institucional
y las reclamos son sectoriales por
supuesto todo esto fogoneado por
utilizar ese término por unas redes
sociales que son omnipresentes en la
actividad Social es decir poniendo la
lupa en el caso francés del que vamos a
hablar por sus elementos también
podríamos hacer trazar lecturas a nivel
internacional muy interesante Jean
Frederick bueno la cuestión democrática
Cómo plantearla si lo que se
sobreentende es que ha habido en las
últimas semanas unos atentados
institucionales contra la democracia es
decir contra la letra de la Constitución
contra el funcionamiento normal de las
instituciones no ha habido crisis
democrática en Francia lo que ha habido
es un enfrentamiento de carácter
efectivamente en parte sectorial en
partes ensanchado y que ha sido de
alguna forma presentado a la opinión
pública como una forma de democracia
alternativa pero no se puede decir de
ninguna maneras ni que el poder
ejecutivo ni El poder legislativo
hayan sobrepasado sus competencias
dentro del marco de la Constitución
Francesa ni tampoco lo que pasa en la
calle porque que ellos sepan no es la
imagen de una dictadura lo que estamos
viendo estos días en la calle Gabriela
lo que podemos la pregunta que nos
podemos hacer es cuál acá en Francia
Cuáles son los límites de esta quinta
República acá en Francia es decir la
gente estaba buscando nuevas formas de
expresión democrática que acá las ha
encontrado a través de la calle a través
también
se está
expresando mucho a través de la
violencia pero lo que tenemos que saber
es qué es lo legal Y qué es lo legítimo
porque lo que se usó esta este decreto
para hacer pasar esta reforma Es legal
pertenece la Constitución no hay nada
ilegal no se ha es decir sin embargo la
gente siente que esto es legítimo por
ser legal podemos aceptarlo y es por eso
que hemos visto a tanta gente salir a la
calle a protestar por un sistema A lo
mejor que ya está encontrando sus
límites es conveniente esa
puntualización no de separarlo Lo legal
de lo legítimo luego vamos a profundizar
en ello pero antes Federico tarragón y
desde la sociólogo de la universidad
París vivero Aunque la semana que viene
parece que se va a retomar el diálogo
por qué están tan degradado el diálogo
entre el gobierno y los llamados cuerpos
intermediarios en Francia el el diálogo
social era algo importante en los años
40 50 o sea de los años de movilización
masiva de los sindicatos Durante los 30
los conglorios los años 40 70 y después
se ha degradado a menudo de la
instalación de las políticas
neoliberales ahora lo que está pasando
Es que la política neoliberal o sea de
imposición por la fuerza del estado de
las leyes económicas de Mercado
se está haciendo de manera siempre más
autoritaria así que lo que era muy
importante en la política francesa O sea
la democracia social no este diálogo
social entre el estado y los sindicatos
ahora no es considerado como algo
central porque consideran que su
legitimidad viene de las urnas Y esta
legitimidad es superior a la que
a la legitimidad relacionadas con el
diálogo entre los
representantes sociales sindicatos
asociaciones movimientos sociales y el
estado es importante también volvemos al
tema de la legitimidad que ya apuntaba
Gabriela y Es verdad que las urnas es
una parte de la Democracia pero también
protestar en la calle es otra parte de
la Democracia es decir No es solo las
urnas No pero lo que se ve en los
últimos años hablando nuevamente de lo
que es la democracia y la percepción de
la democracia en en grandes países
occidentales es que
el voto
no es suficientemente rentable diría yo
decir la gente dice si yo voto pero en
realidad eso no le da la legitimidad al
gobierno o al Estado para hacer lo que
tiene que hacer lo que prometió hacer lo
que a mí no me gusta este es el problema
entonces efectivamente Acá hay una
crisis de algunos sistemas
institucionales es que hay que
modificarlos es que no hay que
modificarlos yo personalmente No creo
que la quinta República francesa esté
llegando a sus límites y yo creo que te
están existen todos los instrumentos
para ejecutar una política democrática y
justa de Justicia social el problema es
Cómo se aplican los instrumentos es como
las redes sociales
porque a lo mejor también el problema es
que Francia no es un país acostumbrado a
coalición parlamentaria Y a partir de
ahí en el momento que se ha perdido una
mayoría absoluta nos hemos encontrado de
repente con esto no vamos a ir luego con
ello la violencia como historiador le
pregunto gianfredick la violencia
protagonizado Las dos últimas jornadas
Después de varias tranquilas es verdad
una buena parte de los franceses ha
responsabilizado al gobierno se está
haciendo el análisis justo del factor de
la violencia estos días el problema como
siempre con esto con estos
acontecimientos es
poder establecer concretamente y
exactamente qué ha ocurrido en cada uno
de los hitos que han sido puestos de
relieve por los medios de comunicación y
como decía Luisa por las redes sociales
lo que a mí me asombra es la velocidad
con la cual el famoso fenómeno viral por
el cual un video tomado con un teléfono
se convierte en verdad Y eso los
periodistas de domingo que lo llaman
ahora y eso eso distorsiona de una forma
absolutamente imparable
la capacidad la capacidad de diagnóstico
real sobre el desenfrenamiento supuesto
de la policía y el desenfrenamiento
supuesto de los manifestantes con la
idea se quita el contexto de en medio
ahí el impacto de una imagen circulando
no hay contexto que el periodismo se
ponerle contexto a las imágenes y es muy
peligroso y es por lo que por lo que no
quiero contestar tu pregunta mientras
porque yo quiero actuar como un juez de
instrucción o sea yo quiero ver los
datos y Mientras no tenga datos no puedo
no puedo opinar de forma
el problema en nuestra sociedad es que
cada vez más estamos basados en La
tiranía de una imagen que Deja fuera el
contexto y nos basamos en ese análisis
caliente de ver imagen tras imagen y de
devorarlas exactamente Gabriela el
problema acá para mí el de la violencia
es que frente a un problema social el
gobierno solamente ha dado una respuesta
policiaca Entonces ha dejado a los
cuerpos sociales a la calle como se le
llama acá estar frente a frente con la
policía cuando la gente está pidiendo
que se que se retire la reforma que se
que se abra el diálogo para ver una
nueva un nuevo tipo de reforma la
respuesta que ha dado el gobierno es
enviar cada vez
contingente policial a las calles hay
que decirlo para para la gente que nos
escucha que los primeros siete actos se
hicieron completamente de una manera
completamente pacífica con pequeños eh
actos de violencia pero marginales
completamente
sin embargo que es lo que ha hecho
estallar esta rabia es el uso del 49 3
que es este decreto que permite votar
esta ley sin pasar por el voto del del
congreso del parlamento entonces lo que
ha comenzado como una reforma contra la
jubilación contra una reforma de las
pensiones
ha abierto una brecha enorme social en
donde ahora han dado cabida a otras
reivindicaciones eso les iba a preguntar
creen que las pensiones es el principal
argumento de un abanico mucho más
amplios de enfados contra el gobierno
que tienen por denominador como un
enfado contra el gobierno pero que ahí
está la subida de precios la ecología es
decir que no todas las personas que
vemos ahí en esas imágenes están
precisamente por la reforma de las
pensiones Luisa desde luego que no es un
Cómo se dice Francia en general estoy
cansado de todo y todo va mal y todo y
nada funciona pero recordemos una cosa
Yo
quiero recordarle a nuestros oyentes que
no conocen profundamente Francia que
este es un país de 68 millones de
habitantes
y que en la manifestación que más gente
reunió reunió un millón doscientas mil
personas en todo el país y que como bien
decías hace un momento no todas esas
personas fueron violentas manifestaron
pacíficamente hay un grupo de
de de de de de de de Pequeños violentos
que están decididos a romper las
manifestaciones y crear ese tipo de
situación y no es solamente ahora que lo
vemos hace años que no estamos viendo
los blackblock existen desde hace años y
el gobierno no podía ser otra cosa más
que dar una respuesta militar Perdón
policial a esa violencia para evitar
otro tipo de cosas porque digamos que
hace dos meses que hay protestas y
violencias y no se produjo una sola
muerte yo quisiera saber en América
Latina qué es lo que hubiera pasado si
estuviéramos en una situación igual voy
a hacer una breve pausa pero enseguida
continuamos hablando de la Reforma de
las pensiones y la movilización en
Francia que en Primera Plana hasta ahora
[Música]
gran expectativa en Nueva York donde ya
se encuentra el expresidente
estadounidense Donald Trump para
comparecer el martes ante el gran Jurado
por el caso de presuntos pagos ilegales
a la actriz estadounidense hay tensión
por posibles protestas masivas de Los
Seguidores del ex jefe de estado
el gobernador del estado estadounidense
de Florida round the Sánchez firmó la
ley que permite portar armas sin permiso
Estatal la medida entre en vigorda es el
primero de julio y con ella quienes por
tener armas no necesitarán capacitación
especial ni verificación de antecedentes
México anunció la muerte de otro de los
migrantes que estuvieron en el incendio
del centro de detención de Ciudad Juárez
lo que elevó el total de fallecidos a 40
a la vez se conocen nuevos testimonios
de supervivientes que revelan el pánico
vivido en el interior del lugar
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos porque hay expectativa y
tensión en la ciudad de Nueva York donde
ya se encuentra el expresidente Donald
Trump quien Este martes tendrá que
presentarse ante una corte de Manhattan
por el caso de los presuntos pagos
ilegales a la actriz pornográfica stormy
Daniels las autoridades se preparan para
posibles masivas protestas de Los
Seguidores del ex mandatario el fiscal
del distrito anunció que dará una
conferencia de prensa luego de la
audiencia Rodrigo cedano tiene los
detalles
Se abrieron las puertas de mar a Lago y
salió la comitiva de seguridad de Donald
Trump en el camino al aeropuerto de Palm
Beach en torno a 200 simpatizantes del
ex presidente y rumbo a Nueva York
en donde más prensa que simpatizantes lo
esperaron frente a la torre trampa
apoyamos a este hombre amamos al
presidente Trump el verdadero presidente
Trump deberá compadecer el martes ante
un juzgado por los presuntos pagos a la
actriz porno stormy Daniels durante la
campaña de 2016 con ello se habría
buscado el silencio de Daniels por una
relación extramatrimonial 10 años antes
un juez que le dirá Cuáles son los
cargos en su contra le preguntará Cómo
se declarará Y en este caso no habrá
fianza Entonces liberará al expresidente
Bajo su propia responsabilidad
también se le tomarán sus huellas una
caza de brujas según sus seguidores
está siendo perseguido políticamente En
mi opinión porque Alvin brack nunca
acusa a los verdaderos criminales la
acusación sin embargo no es por el acto
de pagar por silencio algo que no está
tipificado como delito la ilegalidad
vendría de un presunto registro ilegal
de Los 130.000 dólares pagados como un
reembolso a su abogado Michael cohen
like
Parece que habrá al menos algún fraude
financiero de campaña y que elevaría el
caso de un delito menor a un delito
grave y eso es relativamente grave pero
es la clase de delito grave más baja en
el estado de Nueva York
por el momento la gran manzana refuerza
la seguridad ante un evento tan
relevante para el futuro político del
país se esperan manifestaciones de los
simpatizantes de Trump quien ve como su
popularidad vuelva a aumentar por este
caso el gobernador del estado
estadounidense de Florida el republicano
ron de santis firmó la polémica ley que
permite portar armas de fuego sin
necesidad de permiso Estatal la
normativa entra en vigor el próximo
primero de julio permite que las
personas que lleven armas ocultas en
público no requieran capacitación
especial ni verificación de antecedentes
la iniciativa ha generado un fuerte
rechazo entre los demócratas y
organizaciones sociales que recuerdan
los tiroteos masivos de la discoteca
pauls de Orlando en 2016 con 49 víctimas
mortales y el de la escuela secundaria
Marjorie stonemann Douglas en parkland
en 2018 con 17 muertos
este lunes la secretaría de seguridad de
México informó de la muerte de uno de
los heridos tras el incendio en un
centro de detención migrante en Ciudad
Juárez por lo que los decesos
ascendieron a 40 testimonios de los
sobrevivientes continúan revelando los
detalles de la angustia Que se vivió en
el transcurso de las llamas Rafael Pérez
nos cuenta más
una tragedia que sigue cobrando vidas
este lunes la secretaría de seguridad de
México informó de una nueva muerte a
causa del incendio en un puesto de
detención migrante de Ciudad Juárez con
el fallecimiento Hacienda cuarenta el
número de víctimas de los sobrevivientes
23 se encuentran hospitalizados el
migrante venezolano Edward Caraballo
cuentan lo que vivió durante la
conflagración Duré casi 20 minutos
encerrado ahí a poder 5 minutos Llamando
a mi familia así me contestaba hasta que
día no obviamente para el baño me metí
para el baño me rompí la cara con mi
suéter Edward se encuentra en Estados
Unidos recibiendo tratamiento médico por
sobreexposición al humo la imagen de su
esposa mientras él luchaba por su vida
dio la vuelta al mundo
y mi esposa me cuenta que la mulanza me
parece Pero ahí no sentía nada trataba
débil y gritaba lloraba y hoy gritadme
llorando pero yo no entendía porque
estaba en otro lado pues la compañera de
Edward vinagre Infante también se
encuentra en territorio estadounidense
juntos deben presentarse ahora ante la
autoridad fronteriza hasta el momento
las autoridades mexicanas Han detenido a
cinco personas por los hechos
en otras noticias la presidenta de
Taiwán
continuó su visita por Centroamérica en
Belice donde agradeció por lo que
aseguró es un respaldo a su democracia
Belice junto a Guatemala Son los únicos
dos países de Centroamérica que
mantienen lazos diplomáticos con la isla
y no con china Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplió la
información
la presidente de incluye este lunes una
visita oficial por Centroamérica con un
día ajetreado en Belice en donde asistió
a la cita más importante que era la
presentación de su discurso frente a la
asamblea nacional de Belmopán en sus
declaraciones la mandataria subrayó que
el pueblo de Taiwán enfrenta una amenaza
constante por parte de su vecino frente
al estrecho de Taiwán en Clara
referencia a la china que lideran una
china que acumula provocaciones sobre
todo con el anuncio de hoy de la reunión
oficial que sostendrá la presidentai con
el presidente de la cámara de
representantes de los Estados Unidos
Kevin mccarthy y con otros miembros del
Congreso programada para este miércoles
5 de abril esto en la escala que hará la
mandataria y su delegación en California
luego del viaje por Centroamérica y de
regreso a la isla de Taiwán por su parte
el Primer Ministro John briceño reiteró
el reconocimiento a Taiwán como un
estado le agradeció por la inversión
económica sobre todo por una subvención
de más de 16 millones de dólares para la
construcción de un hospital en el Callo
de uno de los puntos turísticos más
importantes de Belice donde no hay
atención hospitalaria Y esto es un caso
particular porque justamente la
presidenta sai viene de visitar aquí en
Guatemala el hospital de Chimaltenango
cuya construcción se logró por la
inversión taiwanesa de más de 22
millones de dólares pero que ahora está
envuelto en un caso de corrupción por el
cual el viceministro de salud está
encarcelado Fue capturado el
viceministro de salud del gobierno de
Alejandro yamatei Costa Rica ha sido
históricamente uno de los países más
seguros de América Latina pero en los
últimos tiempos se ha convertido en un
punto de almacenamiento y transbordo
para el narcotráfico por lo que han
surgido bandas criminales que llevaron a
registrar un récord de homicidios en
2022 lluís Muñoz nos amplía
es el país de la pura vida y es conocido
por haber sido uno de los más seguros de
América Latina sin embargo la
inseguridad aumenta en Costa Rica una
bala perdida mató en febrero a Samuel
Arroyo de ocho años esto provocó la
indignación Popular
podríamos andar tranquilos hasta ciertas
horas pero ya eso es diferente ha
aumentado mucho la violencia los asaltos
sin importarles que una bala puede herir
a un inocente en 2022 Costa Rica
registró su récord de homicidios con 657
están surgiendo bandas criminales
locales formadas por gente muy joven el
país ha pasado de ser un lugar de paso
para el narcotráfico hacer un punto de
almacenamiento y transbordo de drogas
hacia Europa de eso de comienzos son en
su mayoría a miembros de estructuras
criminales a gatilleros o sicarios o a
personas que tienen algún rol importante
dentro de esas estructuras
ante la búsqueda de soluciones el
ministro de seguridad ha elogiado el
método bukele Mientras que el canciller
fue más cauto en palabras a France 24
durante la Cumbre iberoamericana
nosotros no tenemos un estado de
excepción como en El Salvador Aunque sí
reconocemos que se han incrementado
algunos puntos de inseguridad en el país
sobre todo el asesinato entre bandas de
narcotraficantes es un punto focal que
merece nuestra atención y estamos
haciendo todo esfuerzo para combatirlas
dentro del marco del estado de derecha
Costa Rica ha tenido históricamente una
perspectiva de seguridad relajada sin un
ejército permanente pero la situación
podría cambiar
fin del informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]
France 24 otro punto de vista libertad
seguimos en Primera Plana hablando esta
semana del momento de tensión que vive
Francia vamos a ver si hay luz al final
del túnel o no con las protestas por la
reforma de las pensiones lo hacemos con
Luis acorradini Gabriela Bravo
Federico tarragoni a distancia
bueno por fin durante la jornada del
pasado martes vimos algunos
acercamientos Por fin en la propuesta de
un mediador rechazada por el gobierno
pero a cambio la invitación de reunirse
con Elizabeth Board pero esta situación
se puede superar con la línea roja
puesta en el retraso de jubilación como
parece que tienen esa línea roja Qué
puede haber de margen de maniobra la
semana que viene Gabriela o jedi qué
puede haber en la tabla una palabra yo
creo que
la llave para entender lo que va a
ocurrir la semana que viene es el
resultado de la designación del futuro o
de la futura jefe del principal
sindicato no reformista
y ha sido
pues entonces lo que pasa para nuestros
oyentes y tres espectadores a lo mejor
no conocen la figura Bueno ni siquiera
nosotros Bueno pues es un sindicato no
reformista de tradición Revolucionaria
pero con una un predicamento muy fuerte
tradicional en varios sectores como los
trenes en la electricidad el gas
etcétera Y
es altamente probable que el
planteamiento relativamente dialogante
del anterior
secretario confederal de la sdt no vaya
a repetirse Y eso podría abrir una
brecha dentro de la unidad sindical Lo
que daría a pie paradójicamente a una
posibilidad de negociación Gabriela a mí
me parece que el presidente Manuel
macron se ha encerrado en un callejón
sin salida él ha dicho yo no voy a dar
pie atrás con esta reforma los
sindicatos y la opinión pública hay que
decir que 90% de los trabajadores está
en contra de esta reforma 70 más del 70%
la población francesa está en contra de
esta reforma pese a los actos de
violencia que hemos visto Esto es algo
Bastante inédito lo que no se produjo
con los chalecos amarillos que cuando
comenzaron los actos de violencia la
opinión pública se puso contra en contra
de ellos esto no ha pasado ahora
entonces lo para mí una pequeña
ventanita de salida para el presidente
Manuel macron podría ser el consejo
constitucional quien va el 14 de abril
exactamente que tiene que decir si esta
reforma ha seguido digamos podría usarse
de manera política para dejar en un
empate el balón en el medio del campo y
decir que a lo mejor una parte de esta
reforma va a ser rechazada
constitucionalmente y esto le daría la
posibilidad a entrar a un diálogo a los
sindicatos y al gobierno
analizar políticamente este episodio A
quién puede beneficiar o perjudicar pero
nombrado ese punto de inflexión en la
tensión en las calles cuando llegó con
la aplicación del decreto para aprobar
la reforma con la que se evitó el voto
en la asamblea nacional que en cálculos
del gobierno Tenía muchos riesgos de
perderse aquel voto le pregunto Federico
tarragón y el uso del decreto es
constitucional ya hemos dicho es su
legalidad es Clara la legitimidad y la
protesta aparecen en escena Entonces ha
sido abusivo este uso del decreto que ha
sido lo que ha incendiado las calles
ahí esta posibilidad de utilizar el 49 3
que es un dispositivo jurídico de la
constitución del 58 que acordámoslo para
los que nos están escuchando era
concebido como algo excepcional para
evitar la situación de inestabilidad
característica de la tercera o de la
cuarta República francesa ahora desde
hace
digamos los gobiernos de de macron
esta medida excepcional sea
completamente normalizado y ahí también
con un pasado
cercano que es el gobierno de que la
utilizado también contra
digamos por las políticas antiterrorista
después de los atentados
Así que es Hemos llegado a un estado en
el que está mi vida de excepción sea
completamente banalizado lo que está
pasando Es que las expresiones
contestatarias en las calles son
consideradas democráticamente ilegítimas
por macron como la expresión de una
minoría aunque fuera la mayoría porque
él sabe perfectamente que la mayoría de
los franceses está en contra de esta
reforma de de la jubilaciones Bueno nos
vamos acercando el tema Ya ven ustedes
que los matices en este tema son
fundamentales vamos a hablar de la
política que deja esta situación porque
mirando el futuro del quinquenio y la
agenda de reformas cuando mcgregor por
ejemplo hablan de ampliar esa mayoría
parlamentaria Hacia dónde pueden
dirigirse es decir y ahora que los años
que le quedan a macron ahora pueden
porque parece que los republicanos han
fallado en este pacto seguramente que
fallaron en la administración de esta de
esta de este proyecto
macron en este momento la única
alternativa que tiene la única opción
que tiene es hacer un pacto o una
alianza de gobierno con los republicanos
seguramente no la va a hacer con la
extrema derecha tampoco la va a hacer
con la izquierda que es un grupo
de una especie de de nebulosa en la que
Aparentemente el único que que dirige
las cosas es
decir la extrema izquierda es decir que
la única alternativa que le queda la
única opción que yo veo política dentro
del parlamento es el pacto con los
republicanos pero para eso efectivamente
los republicanos van a tener que poner
orden en sus filas Porque si macron tuvo
que usar el 49 3 fue Sencillamente
porque los republicanos le prometido
hasta dos o tres horas antes que iban a
votar la reforma y a último momento
quince de los diputados republicanos
decidieron que no le iban a votar en
consecuencia no tuvo más remedio
según él en utilizar el 49:3 Quién va a
sacar radio político de toda esta
situación que estamos viviendo ahora hoy
el diario Liberación lo titula
claramente en portada ya Y alfredix dice
Marín Claro pero es que yo creo que eso
es una opinión compartida por
prácticamente toda la opinión digamos de
entre periodistas especialistas de
ciencias políticas
lo está haciendo de forma
extraordinariamente hábil Incluso en el
debate parlamentario cuando se discutió
la ley de jubilaciones
la izquierda pensó que la forma adecuada
de contestar era convertir al parlamento
en área de manifestación en realidad con
abucheos con gritos con todo tipo de
manifestaciones digamos que se salían de
la dignidad parlamentaria mínima del
respeto al paramento como entidad
pública fundamental de la Democracia
representativa mientras que en silencio
y con la sonrisa puesta los diputados
del frente nacional estaban viendo cómo
la izquierda digamos
ridiculizaba el parlamento Y cómo el
bloque presidencial no era capaz de
doblegar Y hacer que ese debate saliera
adelante como un debate digno Entonces
el extrema derecha estaba estaba a sus
anchas viendo lo que estaba ocurriendo y
efectivamente como como decía Luisa la
izquierda no tiene ningún tipo de
capacidad hoy en día de presentar un
programa cohesionado y tiene un problema
de Liderazgo fundamental Porque el único
líder es es un poco como aleja meney en
tipo que digamos es una persona que no
es diputado que no es nada y sin embargo
es que mueve los hilos lo cual demuestra
que el carácter democrático de esa
izquierda es muy relativo Claro porque
he visto desde fuera la gente se podría
preguntar tiene que ser la izquierda que
está en las calles con los sindicatos
quien capitalizará todo esto pero no
parece así Gabriela a lo que podemos ver
de esta estrategia del frente Nacional
del partido de Marín le pen es que ellos
se están preparando para gobernar Qué
quiere decir esto Ellos están siguiendo
todo el conducto constitucional legal
que le ofrece la Constitución y la ley
para manifestarse es decir Proponen un
referendo un referendo para que no se
que no se adopte esta reforma de
jubilaciones que ellos han tomado palco
de estas manifestaciones han dicho
nosotros apoyamos a los manifestantes a
los manifestantes sin embargo nosotros
tenemos un rol parlamentario Qué quiere
decir se están poniendo en el lugar de
que si nos toca gobernar nosotros no
vamos a traer el caos Nosotros somos el
partido del orden y hay que tener bien
en cuenta de que por ejemplo luego de
mayo del 68 vino junio del 68 es decir
luego de este caos y de esta explosión
social vino un los franceses votaron
masivamente por el partido del orden y
esta es la estrategia que está usando
Marín le pen y su partido algo más que
apuntar sobre el tema si yo Estoy
totalmente de acuerdo y lo dicen
claramente porque esta misma semana el
número dos del partido
se le preguntó por televisión Y ahora
cuál es el próximo paso y él lo dijo
claramente dijo el próximo paso que
frente nacional llegue al poder Federico
tarragón y sociólogo de la universidad
París diderot volvamos a la violencia la
confrontación no quiere decir violencia
y en el caso de las manifestaciones
contra esa reforma se documenta el uso
desproporcionado en algunos casos Cómo
analizar ese uso de la fuerza que del
que hemos hablado antes en la mesa
se corrigió en buena parte en la última
jornada hay una un historiador francés
de la Revolución Francesa que ha hablado
de una tradición propia a la Francia del
extremo centro es
la la idea que
las ideas centrales moderadas
son deben ser aplicadas de manera casi
más radical que
los las otras posiciones políticas o sea
el extremo centro lucha contra los
extremos a la izquierda y a la derecha
pero es un extremo también eso es lo que
está pasando con la policía la la
policía reprime la las manifestaciones
de manera anticipada y con un uso de la
fuerza que es que es totalmente
ilegítimo Ah la doctrina la dicha
doctrina francesa de de de de de de de
de de de de de de de de de la fuerza del
orden se está degradando completamente
todas las encuestas lo muestran hay un
gobierno que considera que su proyecto
tiene que ser aprobado cualquier Cuál es
que fueran las medidas y queréis a la
policía
sea libres de reprimir Porque de todas
formas este proyecto tiene que pasar
últimas conclusiones que me queda ya muy
poquito tiempo sobre lo que hemos
escuchado Jean Frederick tenemos un
sistema político el de la quinta
república que es está basado en el
frentismo y está basado en el carisma Y
eso es totalmente contrario a la idea de
pacto Gabriela respecto a esta violencia
el presidente y el gobierno apostaron
por que esto se pudiera es porque la
violencia trajera de nuevo a la
población hacia la aprobación del
gobierno Y esto no ha dado efecto y es
una estrategia que no le ha funcionado
antes
yo creo que el problema acá es
efectivamente la falta de tradición de
diálogo y de pacto que existe en esta
sociedad francesa en los últimos años
Muchísimas gracias a los cuatro ha sido
un placer muy esclarecedor hablar con
ustedes en este momento de tanta tensión
aquí en Francia de todos ustedes hasta
la próxima semana quien en Primera Plana
gracias
[Música]